felt good
um know all things
considered felt really
good where did the defensive game fall
off uh it falls off and having Pride um
just got to have pride in yourself as a
man that I'm not going to let my gu
score and
you our clothes outs was too soft our
rotations were too slow um so it's just
no Pride like and
until every guy take pride in themselves
and want to stop the guy in front of
them we'll
suck um
they're all
concerning but what they all say is we
can't
check turnovers are what they
are don't really worry about the
turnovers um we've been good at not
turning the ball over
but we can't guard nobody so until we
guard we'll
lose um everything it starts on the at
the it starts with the person on the
ball and everybody else behind um it's
everybody it's not just one
person
uh individuals make up a team
and individually our defense suck so in
turn our team defense
suck